on the streets of an American city what
looks a lot like a war this is the fight
against a drug now sweeping the country
we have no drug problem that's ever had
the body count behind it the deaths
related to it as what we're seeing with
the fentanyl product
those deaths all ages all races rich and
poor just the tiniest drop it killed him
it's become an epidemic the authorities
can't control you're definitely playing
Russian roulette with your life
welcome to the reality of America's
deadliest we're in a supermarket carpark
in Phoenix in Arizona okay guys so looks
like we're about to have some action
here so I'm going to kill the engine
watch the dark pickup truck on the
right-hand side moving in see how
they're blocking him in seconds later so
we've got two in custody right now the
SWAT team has arrested two men in a car
they thought they were coming to sell
drugs in fact the buyer they've been
talking to was an agent from the US Drug
Enforcement Administration the SWAT team
takes no chances
her car is clear the agents are
targeting fentanyl the synthetic opioid
that last year killed 31,000 people in
America in the car in a bag wrapped to
look like burritos thousands of deadly
pills it was also a loaded and cocked
handgun they have the the dope that we
wanted which is ten thousand fentanyl
tablets you're looking at twenty twenty
bucks 25 bucks a pill so you're looking
at several hundred thousand dollars
worth of pills and lethality right I
mean that that 10,000 of those pills if
those are all two milligram pills we're
talking about the potential to kill ten
thousand people when they opened those
wrappers this is what they found
fentanyl disguised as regular
painkillers either like this or as
powder cartels in Mexico a flooding
America with the drug there's no way to
tell if one of these has 2 milligrams of
fentanyl in it or if it has 5 milligrams
of fence only in it - you might survive
5 you definitely won't so anytime
somebody takes these these illicit ones
you're definitely playing Russian
roulette with your life
legitimate fentanyl was designed for use
in hospitals
but 50 times more powerful than heroin
it's attracted those chasing a new high
we have no drug problem that's ever had
the body count behind it the deaths
related to it as what we're seeing with
the fentanyl product the fentanyl and
the opiate problem that we have here
it's hitting everybody
it hits every class it's every race it's
every socio-economic demographic it hits
everything we've developed an entire
generation of people that are addicted
to opiates [ __ ] shion's oxycodone
hydrocodone things like that and what
that's led to is an increase in heroin
addiction and fall and subsequently an
increase in the fentanyl product opiate
addicts will always continue to chase
that first high so once they get
addicted to these drugs they're always
going to be looking for a more powerful
substance to get them back to that first
high how they first felt when they took
him sometimes that's a switch to heroin
and now what we see in the last three or
four years it's a switch to a drug
called fentanyl
the SWAT team has moved on to the home
of one of the men they arrested
a man inside what they call the stash
houses taken away there's also a woman
and two young children inside it is a
detached house in a quiet residential
cul de sac in it police find a stack of
assault weapons and more fentanyl well
some of this fentanyl undoubtedly ends
up on the streets of Phoenix most of it
is destined elsewhere this is a major
hub on the route from the cartels in
Mexico to the big cities of Detroit and
Chicago and st. Louis we are standing on
the supply line right into the heart of
America's opioid crisis it's 1500 miles
from Phoenix to st. Louis where the
marketplace is vast and growing and
where fentanyl has taken a deadly hold
he was the most kind the most loving so
full of love but he was a heroin addict
Eli Randall was in recovery from his
addiction when his mother found him dead
in his bedroom in May a relapse what he
thought was heroin was far more powerful
fentanyl there is worse times I cannot
tell you how many times I had to go up
those steps to his bedroom that I could
hardly put one foot in front of the
other because I was terrified of what I
would find he there was times he was in
such bad shape and so anytime he didn't
wake up or he didn't show up or he
didn't come down you just you couldn't
hardly bear to go up there for what you
might find and that morning I bounced up
the steps and never ever ever occurred
to me what I would find just the tiniest
drop of it killed him he had no clue
what he had and he had no intention of
leaving us and I'll never be able to say
I have everything ever again because
there's a place that
just be empty forever on November 18th
2018 he tweeted a post that said someday
my story will inspire someone else to do
better for themselves so that is what
myself and my family are trying to do is
help someone else do better for
themselves at this Outreach Center in
st. Louis they stopped the medication
called narcan it reverses the effects of
an opioid overdose only about one in
seven overdoses are fatal the rest
survived but the users who come here say
they regularly see people die the lure
of fentanyl high is just too strong I
don't think it's that we're gonna stop I
wish it could anyway but I don't I don't
see that happening it's too big
everywhere the Outreach Center is run by
recovering addicts they say the
solutions to America's opioid epidemic
lies with a change of government
attitude we have to systematically do
the things definitely I've to look at
other countries that have reversed
epidemics none of those countries use
the tactics we're talking about in the
states they decriminalize they created
more access to treatment they opened
safe injection sites they did the
opposite of what our government right
now is proposing we as Americans are
willing to spend forty four thousand
dollars to lock somebody up this year
right for one year but we're not willing
to take 10,000 of that invested upfront
on getting them treatment on what is
really driving the addiction not
surprisingly then they're dismissive of
a new White House plan to tackle the
trafficking of fentanyl and those on the
front line are seeing a surge in the
drug coming across the border the DEA
and Border Protection officers say
seizures are on the rise the drug often
mixed in makeshift labs run by the
cartels in Mexico replacing shipments
from China as the major source of
fentanyl stopping it all they say is
almost impossible as long as American
citizens still want these
products though they'll always find a
way to get it in here but you're talking
about it a substance is so powerful that
a kilogram of it 1 kilo 2 pounds 2.2
pounds you can potentially make 500,000
pills out of that which could
potentially kill 250 or 300 thousand
Americans so you're talking about really
small amounts of stuff that come across
and it's very difficult to detect it
back in st. Louis the Outreach Center
has bought an old ambulance to reach
those who can't reach them in this city
they say there is almost no heroin on
the streets anymore it is all fentanyl
right now I'm just giving our Lohan
it took miles 20 attempts to beat his
own addiction delivering narcan to users
in the hope it will save them or someone
else is his way of giving back and
persuading others to find a better way
out using fentanyl is a really good way
to turn your brain off for a little bit
and not have to think about how hungry
you are or how poor you are or how you
haven't been able to change your clothes
in a couple weeks it's a really good way
to turn that off it turns everything
else off too the thing is so many other
folks have turned their backs to people
who are using fentanyl and that's when
people need human connection the most I
have hope
I believe in recovery I don't believe
addicts all die I believe people recover
and I have hope I thought that if I lost
the eye I wouldn't have hope anymore and
yet I still have hope and that I would
help anybody who needed help illicit
fentanyl is just the latest wave in the
opioid crisis in a country with 5% of
the world's population but using 85% of
the world's opioids and a seemingly
ready supply to meet the demand
Greg Milam Sky News